Je suis vraiment fier de toi pour
ce voyage, tu vas
t'amuser tellement et te rappeler que quelque chose te poursuit
[Musique]
cours [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous avons appris davantage au cours de la dernière décennie
de la génétique qu'un siècle de déterrement d'
os, une toute nouvelle frontière s'est
ouverte, nous avons notre premier hybride génétiquement
modifié,
vous venez de créer un nouveau
dinosaure, aidez-moi à ne pas
comprendre que mon mur mesurait 40 pieds de haut, je pense vraiment
qu'elle est sortie, cela dépend de
quel genre de dinosaure ils ont
concocté dans ce
laboratoire Évacuez l'
île [Musique] c'est un animal très intelligent,
elle tuera tout ce qui
bouge, oh mon Dieu [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Musique]
cours